president Trump's lawyer Rudy Giuliani
says Robert Muller is not going to
indict President Trump but Robert Muller
is still digging Michael Cohen finds
himself on the wrong end of leaks again
and the media lie about President Trump
and immigration I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
so today is the day folks if you've not
heard already I'm taking Ben Shapiro
shall live to audiences in Dallas and
Phoenix presale tickets have been going
extremely fast particularly our VIP
packages I think they're very few left
in fact there's been such demand from
our subscribers we've asked the venue's
to open up 50 additional VIP tickets at
each event because we're getting a lot
of complaints that they were sold out
already today is the final day for
premium subscribers to get your presale
tickets so if you're not a subscriber
you should subscribe so that we can get
access to the tickets because tonight at
10 p.m. local time
everyone gets access to the tickets
tonight at 10 p.m. everyone gets access
to the tickets whether you remember
whether or not a member you can now buy
a ticket at 10 p.m. tonight wherever you
are seats will go fast for both VIP and
general sales tickets if you are not
already a subscriber again be sure to
sign up now and get that presale code
and you can get early access to the best
seats in the house go to Daley wired.com
slash events to get your presale tickets
an additional info again that's Daley
wire.com / events to get an presale
tickets an additional info I'm really
pumped to be bringing the show live to
folks the tickets are going incredibly
fast and getting a lot of notes from
people you know begging pleading for
extra tickets so we opened up a few
extras so please go check it out and I
promise it's gonna be a fun event and I
want to be it'll be a big blast before I
get into the news and there's a lot of
news to get in today first I want to say
thanks to our sponsors over at Legal
Zoom so pretend you're in the government
you need legal help for just a second
well people you would go to our the
folks over at legal zooms that you're
not spending hundreds of thousands of
dollars on legal work because attorneys
are super expensive you're gonna pay 300
bucks an hour for probably an associate
when I was an associate at a top law
firm they were charging 250 bucks an
hour for my time that was like 10 years
ago
hey you could otherwise go to Legal Zoom
and they don't have to pay that 2
million Americans have used legal zooms
to start their business with LLC's
incorporation and more but even after
your business is set up Legal Zoom can
still help you out things like lease
agreements changing tax laws contract
reviews they're all part of running your
own business but these are precisely the
kinds of legal hurdles that do take time
and effort away from your growing
business which is why Legal Zoom has
created their business legal plan so
this is pretty awesome with it you get
legal advice for your business from
vetted independent attorneys and tax
professionals available in every state
you also receive access to NDA's lease
agreements and more in the best part is
you're not gonna get charged by the hour
because Legal Zoom is not a law firm
instead you just pay one low upfront
price so this is going to save you a ton
of money legal costs are extraordinarily
expensive check out Legal Zoom is
misleading plan at legalzoom.com right
now
and get special savings when you enter
promo code been at checkout again
legalzoom.com enter promo code Bennett
check out Legal Zoom is where life meets
legal let them know we sent you by using
that promo code bed and get their
special deal alrighty so the news of the
day is that the media are just garbage
I'm sorry I've been railing against the
use of the term fake news for years on
this program when it does not apply when
President Trump says that it's fake news
for example that the media are
misreporting his crowd size that's not
fake news but this week I have to tell
you it's an amazingly I'm getting notes
from people I'm getting texts from
people people who did not vote for Trump
in the last election who are now telling
me either they're turning me into a
Trumpkin the media are turning me into a
huge Donald Trump fan why because the
great arbiters of truth and decency
these wonderful arbiters of all that is
good in the world it turns out they are
objectively lying about issues ranging
from Hamas to now ms-13 so the
democratic new playbook I guess for 2018
is defend calm us defend ms-13 and rip
on the NRA that's the new playbook from
the Democrats and the media are
parroting that every step of the way
what am I so hot and bothered about
today well we'll get to the Hamas
coverage in just a second but here's
what I'm really hot and bothered about
today president Trump yesterday was
doing an event with much of sheriff's
from all over the country and one of the
sheriffs mentioned ms-13 and President
Trump responded in this way here's clip
three we had people coming into the
country of trying to come and we're
stopping a lot of them but we're taking
people out of the country you wouldn't
believe how bad these people these are
people these are animals and we're
taking them out of the country at a
level at a rate that's never happened
before okay so here is the reality what
Trump was specifically specifically
talking about was ms-13 because the line
that led up to this was a sheriff saying
we can't actually deport ms-13 people
the line leading up to this there's a
sheriff named Mims who said thank you
there could be an ms-13 member I know
about if they don't reach a certain
threshold I cannot tell ice about it and
then Trump responded to the ms-13
reference by saying we have people
coming into the country but we're taking
people out of the country wouldn't
believe how bad these people are these
aren't people these are animals so how
did the media cover this he's
specifically talking about ms-13 it is
obvious that he's talking about ms-13 it
is clear that he's talking about ms-13
and that's 13 actual tagline I mean this
is their actual marketing lines that our
members
is rape steal control these are not good
people they are in fact as close to
animals as you'll find in human beings
so how did the media report this let me
show you how the media report this
here's the New York Times so this is
what they tweeted out Trump lashed out
at undocumented immigrants during a
White House meeting calling those trying
to breach the country's borders animals
no he didn't he did not lash out at all
illegal immigrants he lashed out at
ms-13 and they are animals there have
been several stories in the last couple
of years about ms-13 members literally
ripping hearts out of bodies while the
people are still alive beheading their
political enemies bringing drugs into
the country and this 13 are some of the
worst people on planet earth if the if
the descriptor animal does not apply to
ms-13 and legitimately applies to no one
and yet the media are trying to plate as
though Trump is not talking about ms-13
instead Trump was talking about illegal
immigrants at large Ellison Trump has
had some bad stuff about illegal
immigration generally and he's been over
brought in his language that's not what
happened here
what happened right here was that he was
ripping on ms-13 and the media decided
to deliberately take him out of context
and it wasn't just the New York Times
it was c-span he was CNN it was the New
York Times it was the Washington Post
they all decided to report this as
though Trump was talking about illegal
immigrants more broadly they were lying
they were lying and these lies have been
very typical of the media this entire
week this entire week we've heard from
the media that innocents were killed on
the border between Gaza and Israel
except for the fact that Hamas admitted
yesterday that 50 of the 62 people
killed were Hamas members and another
three were members of Islamic Jihad so
53 out of the 62 people killed were
active terrorists who works for active
terrorist groups designated as such by
the State Department and the media
covered it as though this is all Trump's
fault that evil evil Trump and Hamas
bunch of innocent folks and now it's
ms-13 like really this is the Train you
want to jump on media you hate Trump so
much that you're going to deliberately
take him out of context and then you
wonder why we don't trust the media and
one of the great myths about President
Trump is that people on the right don't
like the media because Trump doesn't
like the media nonsense people on the
right like Trump because Trump doesn't
like the media okay we didn't like the
media a long time ago as I said at CPAC
my entire career we've spent thinking
the media are totally full of it I
remember my parents canceling their
subscriptions and Los Angeles Times in
the mid 90s over there
average of Israel the media has always
been egregiously bad but this last week
has been just an incredible
demonstration of how bad they are
and this is why you wonder why people
are resonating to president Trump you
wonder why because Trump will take a
stand like ms-13 are a bunch of animals
or like Hamas is bad and when they put
people in front let me put terrorists
behind human shields in an attempt to
get people killed for the cameras that's
bad and he's right about both those
things and the media because they hate
Trump so much decide to side with Hamas
inside with ms-13 and then we're
supposed to side with the media we're
supposed to believe the media's
narrative about Trump we're supposed to
believe what the media have to say about
truth and honor and how there's just
fire fighters running to the fire they
have no agenda
their objective their truthful bull
bleep okay that is nonsense and
everybody knows that's nonsense no
members of the media you want to regain
your credibility you wonder why the
American people don't trust you because
you don't deserve their trust because
you are not acting in trustworthy
fashion because you are acting in many
cases as fake news and in many other
cases as biased news this is really
egregious stuff this is what's gonna put
people into Trump's camp because this
week I gotta tell you I was thinking
about President Trump and what he did
with regard to Jerusalem and what he's
been saying but I must 13and and then
I've been watching the media and I gotta
tell you if the media want me to make a
decision between Trump and Hamas that's
not much of a choice it's not much of a
choice I've been very critical of
president Trump's character but you
can't lie about the guy to get him
members of the media get idiots you
can't lie about him he can't fib about
him you can't manipulate events on the
ground you can't ignore the truth about
what's happening all over the world
simply in order slap at President Trump
if you do it's just going to drive
people into Trump's camp let's talk
about top member of the Trump
administration is a few months ago and I
was discussing you know how is Trump
going to win the votes necessary in
order to win reelection like to have a
plan for this because george w bush lost
the popular vote in 2000 by 500,000
votes and then he won by about 1.5
million votes against john kerry but he
had to pick up about 10 to 11 million
votes between 2000 and 2004 in order to
win reelection because the electorate
expands every year well president Trump
lost the popular vote this year by order
this election cycle by about two and a
half million votes that means that he's
going to have to make up probably twelve
million votes in order for him to win
reelection
I said to this member of the Trump
administration how do you plan on
winning 12 million additional votes how
do you plan on bringing a bunch of
people over and there wasn't a great
answer so part of it is gonna be good
policy obviously but part of it is going
to be shifting definitions of Trump well
one of the ways that you can shift the
definition of Trump is not by shifting
who Trump is but by the media making
themselves so much worse than they
already were that you feel like you're
being forced to choose between the media
and Democrats who are lying on a routine
basis and defending the worst people on
the planet and President Trump now
there's a case that was made during the
last election cycle that it was a binary
choice between Hillary Clinton and
President Trump this was not a logical
case that I agreed with I thought there
was a third choice and it was to stay
home but the worst the Democrats get the
worst the media get the more it looks
like a binary choice and the better
Trump governs the more it looks like a
binary choice you want to push people
into Trump's camp guys you are doing an
excellent job that speaking of doing an
excellent job of pushing people into
Trump's camp there's a there's a person
named Juanita Scarlett the money no
Scarlett went to a party at Dom lemons
house okay and Don Lemon had at his
house Errol Lewis who's a commentator at
CNN and Margaret Hoover who's another
commentator at CNN and some lemon news
reporter at CNN and guess who was over
at John lemons house and they all took a
selfie together
he was Michael avenatti hey the lawyer
for stormy Daniels there they are just
grinning right there look at that the
objective journalist grinning with
Michael avenatti now imagine for a
second that say Michael cone had been
invited to Sean Hannity's house you
think people might have gone nuts they
did okay there was that entire week
where all we could talk about was the
fact that Michael Cohen and Sean Hannity
had been discussing issues but somehow
Michael avenatti going to down lemons
house and hanging out there right that's
not a problem at all and then you wonder
why we think the media are not objective
you wonder why so many people are
turning to President Trump and saying
not not interested in in in siding
against Trump and with the media it's
just it's insanity its total insanity
and if the media wish to keep alienating
people maybe they do maybe that's their
goal maybe their goal is to make
President Trump from president for
another term they could do it they could
make it happen all they have to do is
continue being who they are I wrote a
column earlier this week about comedy in
in culture and how the right wing's
response to comedy is not for us to
generate our own comedians it's to elect
from because Trump's a giant middle
finger it's the entire comedic
establishment you make a bunch of Trump
jokes about Trump you make a bunch of
jokes about us well screw you will elect
that guy well the same thing is true the
media remember in 2012 Newt Gingrich
nearly won the Republican nomination
based simply on ripping on an anchor at
one of his debates that's how much we
despise the media and we don't despise
the media for no reason we despise the
media because since 2001 when bias came
out by bernard goldberg there has been a
20-year campaign by the right against
bias in the media and the media's
response has not been to try and
moderate to try and hire some people who
are conservative to try and hire some
people who might balance things out
their goal has not been to strip out
their own opinions it's been to
exacerbate the involvement of their own
opinions now maybe it helps their
ratings maybe it's good for CNN maybe
it's good for MSNBC but that just
demonstrates once and for all they care
more about ratings than they do about
truth they know where has that been true
then with regard to the situation along
the border in Gaza I'm going to talk
about that in just one second but first
I want to say thanks to our friends over
at my Patriot supply so tornadoes in the
South three earthquakes in four days in
Oregon Kilauea is erupting in Hawaii no
matter where he lived there's always the
possibility of natural disasters right
there's always that possibility and most
of these strike with no warning
the truth is you are the best first
responder the alternative is to wait for
the government and you know that might
not be the best idea because the fact is
that the chances that the government is
going to show up on time not really
great not really great I'll take them a
little while to get to you at the very
best this is why you need to get this
Ben Shapiro special offer from my
Patriot supply by one four week
emergency food kit for just 198 bucks
and get one for free again one four week
emergency food kit for just $198 and get
one for free it's a two for one so you
get buy one get one free and when you
purchase one right now
my pager supply sends you that
additional four week food kit for free
eight eight eight eight oh three
fourteen thirteen order online and
prepare with been calm that's prepared
with Ben calm the food last in storage
for twenty five years and these shipped
for free so you just buy it once and
you're not gonna have to worry about it
again
instead you buy it you stick it in the
closet and then you're the most prepared
person on the block go check it out
eight eight eight eight oh three
fourteen thirteen or online at prepare
with Ben calm that is prepare with Ben
calm go check it out you will be very
happy that you did okay so speaking of
the media coverage on the on the Gaza
border
there's a piece today from Kinley tor
Paz can liter Paz is a is a founder and
CEO of the kyboot sadati educational
network in Israel and he has a report at
times of Israel on what actually
happened on the border with Gaza so he
says he says I want to testify to what I
saw and heard it was a tremendous
supreme effort from our side to prevent
in every possible way Palestinian deaths
and injuries of course the primary
mission was to prevent hundreds of
thousands of Gazans from infiltrating
into our territory that kind of invasion
would be perilous mortally dangerous to
the nearby communities would permit
terrorists disguised as civilians to
enter our kyboots and moshav communities
and would leave us with no choice but to
target every single infiltrator that's
why our soldiers were directed to
prevent infiltration in a variety of
ways using live ammunition only as a
last resort the IDF employs many
creative means of reducing friction with
gazans and uses numerous methods most of
which are not made public to prevent
them from reaching the fence in addition
over the past few weeks there have been
serious efforts to save the lives of
children and civilians who have been
pushed to the frontlines by Hamas or
trying to hide behind them in order to
infiltrate and attack Israel when there
is no alternative and live ammunition
must be used to stop those who storm the
fence the soldiers make heroic and
sometimes dangerous efforts not to kill
and totally injure those on the other
side which is why you see so many leg
wounds on the side of Hamas the IDF
stations senior commanders at every
confrontation point to ensure that every
shot is approved and backed up by a
responsible figure with proper Authority
every staging area has an especially
large number of troops in order to make
sure that soldiers are not put in
life-threatening situations where
they'll have no choice but to fire
indiscriminately a situation where
thousands of people rush you is
frightening even terrifying it is
extremely difficult to show restraint
and it requires calm mature
professionalism 62 dead is an enormous
number but I can testify from first-hand
experience every bullet every hit is
carefully reported documented and
investigated and Excel spreadsheets
literally I was there I saw it with my
own eyes so again the the media are
reporting this as those an
indiscriminate kill fast over at the
Gaza border even while Hamas is
admitting it was not an indiscriminate
kill fast over at the Gaza border and
the Israelis didn't have much of a
choice here what do you want everybody
to just run through the border then you
have to mow down hundreds of people 100
people the media have covered it as
though this is all Israel's fault and
the media know the media know exactly
what they are doing there's no doubt
that the media know exactly what they
are saying by the way speaking of the
media malfeasance
the AP has
deleted its tweet from wins from
Wednesday on Trump's animals comments
about immigrants because it wasn't made
clear he was speaking after a comment
about gang members so now the media are
gonna have to walk back all of this in
real time they're gonna have to walk
back all of this in real time again not
shocking but look how the Democrats
played this up when it first came out
Chuck Schumer the Senate Majority Leader
he tweeted out when all of our
great-great-grandparents came to America
they weren't animals and these people
aren't either supposedly referring to
illegal immigrants and when my
great-great grandparents came to America
they didn't join gangs and cut the
hearts out of living human beings I'm
pretty sure Chuck Schumer's didn't
either but the media malfeasance here is
falling right into president Trump's
hands I guess I should be happy about it
I guess I should be happy it's making
Republicans more popular but I'm more
unhappy about untruth than unhappy about
the effects of the untruth even if they
cut in my favor okay meanwhile there's a
lot of news today breaking in the Moller
case a lot of see a lot of discussion
about what's going on with Rob Malley
Rudy Giuliani who is Trump's new lawyer
he was on Laura Ingraham show last night
and he said that Robert Muller has now
announced that he will not in fact
indict President Trump if they subpoena
us challenge the subpoena the same
reason they can't indict him
constitutional which Muller agreed today
he's gonna buy no indictment of the
president but I don't think they agree
to the process question which is the
same reason they can't indict him they
can't issue a subpoena tip and remember
Clinton opposed the subpoena and then he
voluntarily complied he didn't give up
presidential prerogative and then his
administration wrote a memo saying they
can't do that so legally speaking it is
true that the president could be
indicted by robert muller probably
robert miller said look I'd rather leave
this to the political process as opposed
to a criminal indictment if in fact he
has anything this doesn't mean that
President Trump is off the hook with
regard to Robert Muller Rudy Giuliani
says listen there's no collusion there's
no evidence of collusion but he does say
well there's kind of evidence that there
was intent to collude but that is not
the same thing as collusion which is of
course exactly what I said on
yesterday's show their inability to
reach a conclusion that is obvious and
their unwillingness to recognize the
damage that's does to our country all
over the world there's no reason for
this investigation there never was a
good reason for in the first place
this was engineered by call me with them
with them with the
the report not to report that the
interview thing that he wrote that he
should have never revealed so now I want
to go through the the full news about
what Robert Muller is doing because
there's a lot of news that broke
yesterday on this well the news begins
with the Senate Intel report so
president Trump's son Donald Jr was
responsible for setting up a meeting
with a russian warrior named natalia
vessel met skya at trump tower president
of this meeting supposedly were Jared
Kushner I believe Paul Manafort was
present at the meeting if I'm not
mistaken and and other members top
members of the Trump administration
apparently Kushner got up and left after
about five minutes and there are other
people who are there who also left
realizing that thing was a boondoggle
but the original pitch by the Russian
lawyer and her and her advocate who was
a friend of the Trump family was that
she was going to give them information
about Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump
jr. had written that they were very
excited about that and the email
exchange with with this guy who had been
pitching the Russian lawyer suggested
that the Russian government was
supportive of President Trump in the
election cycle and Trump jr. expressed
his enthusiasm for that well the Senate
interviewed Donald Jr then they released
hundreds of pages of interview
transcript yesterday The Associated
Press reports on it they say question
intently by Senate committee president
Donald Trump's son struck a firmly
unapologetic tone deflected many queries
and said he didn't think there was
anything wrong with meeting a Russian
lawyer at Trump Tower in hopes of
elections he's in dirt on Hillary
Clinton according to transcripts
released on Wednesday Trump jr. speaking
in a closed-door interview last year
with the Senate Judiciary Committee said
he did not give much thought to the idea
that the June 9th 2016 meeting was part
of a Russian government effort to help
his father in the presidential race he
said I don't know that it alarmed me but
like I said I don't know and I don't
know that I was all that focused on it
at the time the committee released about
2,500 pages of interview transcripts and
other documents tied to the New York
meeting which Trump jr. attended the
transcripts also shows some new details
and they they show how the meeting was
arranged and efforts afterward to
mitigate the political damage from the
meeting itself the transcripts also
reflect an aggressive Russian outreach
to Trump before and after the New York
meeting including an effort to a range
of follow-up get-together that November
with a member of the transition team the
follow up never happened however Rob
Goldstone who is the the fixer-upper he
promised him very he promised from jr.
very interesting information from a
well-connected Russian lawyer including
documents that would incriminate Hillary
Clinton and Trump jr. responded via
email if it's what you say
that came out last year throughout the
private Senate interview Trump jr. said
he didn't recall if he had talked with
his father about it he didn't really
there was apparently a call in the call
log several days before the meeting took
place with a caller with a blocked
number
Trump jr. said he didn't recall who the
person was and didn't know if his father
used the block number I have to imagine
that Muller is going to find out whether
that is the case or not in any case
there is no actual information that
suggests that information passed hands
between the Trump campaign and the
Russian government or that the Rizzo 'pn
coordination or covert coordination
between the Russian government and the
Trump campaign however however if you
had this information if this information
was available to Robert Muller or to
James Comey or anybody else it would not
be out of lines who launched an
investigation based on this information
okay then there's a lot of talk today
about witch hunt witch on witch hunt I
agree there's been no actual evidence
presented to date of serious collusion
between the Trump campaign and everybody
else but that's not the same thing as
saying the investigation itself was
initiated for bad reasons or that it's
been conducted in the wrong way I'll
explain what I mean in just a second
because I think that we have to stick to
the facts as much as we possibly can
when it comes to this Muller
investigation and I want to break it
down for you in just a moment first I
want to say thanks to our sponsor is
over at policy genius so you don't have
life insurance you don't have life
insurance because you thought about it
you thought I'm gonna live today I'm
gonna live tomorrow I'm not gonna die
ever well wrong you are one day you will
indeed plotz and when you do you want to
make sure that your family has enough
money to keep on keeping on and that's
why you need to go over to policy genius
80% of people think life insurance costs
double what it actually does it's not
that expensive a healthy 35 year old can
get half a million bucks in coverage for
less than 30 bucks a month
this is totally worthwhile because once
you're dead you don't have the time to
regret it anymore
policy genius is the easy way to compare
life insurance online in just five
minutes you can compare quotes from the
top insurance to find the best policy
for you policy genius has helped over 4
million people shop for insurance placed
over 20 billion dollars in coverage and
they don't just make life insurance easy
they also compare disability insurance
and renters insurance and health
insurance if you care about it then they
can cover it so if you've been thinking
about getting life insurance go to
policy genius com it's the easy way to
compare the top insurers and find the
best policy for you you will be saving
time money and hassle and it's free
checking out policy genius because
comparing life insurance does not need
to be a pain in the neck
check out policy genius make sure that
your family is protected okay so as I
say a bunch of stories released from the
sort of
investigation one was the Senate Intel
investigation of Donald Trump were
interview with Donald Trump and this was
supposedly the this this demonstrated
obviously the Donald Trump jr. was
interacting with agents of Russia maybe
in an attempt to collude but there's no
actual evidence of collusion then there
was this other big story and this is the
one where a lot of folks on the right I
think are miss reading the situation ok
this story's from the New York Times it
says code name crossfire hurricane the
secret origins of the Trump
investigation now remember the going
theory here is that the FBI under
President Obama was interested in
undermining the Trump campaign during
the campaign by investigating and then
presumably putting out information to
undermine President Trump during the
campaign this is the going theories that
this is all trumped up it was all put
together on kind of spit and glue that
they just decided they were gonna get
Trump in the middle of the election
cycle that they work to let Hillary
Clinton off the hook and then they
worked to go after President Trump with
nothing to verify it they worked to
target his campaign right he was wiretap
in the words of President Trump that he
was targeted now even if presidents from
Post quote unquote wiretap
he was not wired tapped at Trump Tower
but even if there was surveillance of
particular members of the Trump campaign
like Carter page that does not
necessarily demonstrate that
surveillance was inappropriate or than
anything wrong happened with the
surveillance well this story from the
New York Times yesterday has a lot of
people on the right saying that there is
something deeply nefarious that was
going on at the FBI during the campaign
the biggest question that I have about
this is if you really believe that the
FBI and the CIA and the DOJ are all
working very hard to try and discredit
the Trump campaign and to put out
information that Trump was in in thrall
to Russia then why didn't any of this
information come out during the campaign
you were there I was there if they
wanted to sing Trump during the campaign
wouldn't it have been useful for them to
say that Paul Manafort
was under in was under investigation
like from the very first day wouldn't it
have been useful for them to say that we
suspect that there is collusion between
the Trump campaign and the Russian
government wouldn't that be like a
useful thing to have put out there on a
routine basis because it's consumed the
news cycle ever since but most of this
stuff broke after Trump was actually
elected so if you were inside the
quote-unquote deep state you wanted to
take down Trump there in the election
cycle why wouldn't you put it out early
now the theory is that they didn't put
this out early because it was an
insurance policy in case Trump
came president they thought Hillary was
gonna win anyway that makes no sense
that doesn't make any sense it's not
that this was an insurance policy in
case Trump became president yeah that's
that silly okay instead what it sounds a
lot more like is if in the theory of the
right these were arsonists they were
trying to set a fire so if you're trying
to set a fire why wait till the guys
elected president to set the fire why
not set the fire in the middle of the
campaign that's question number one
question number two is can you point to
any actual nefarious activity that you
would have objected to if Hillary
Clinton had been the target of it so I
have a very simple rule that I've been
using for years put the shoe on the
other foot so I'm gonna read this story
and for a second I want you to assume
that it's about Hillary Clinton and not
Donald Trump and then think are you
angry that this investigation was going
on in the first place these I don't want
to impugn people's motives or honor
based on partisan concerns so here it is
from the New York Times within hours of
opening investigation into the Trump
campaigns ties to Russia in the summer
of 2016
the FBI dispatched a pair of agents to
London on a mission so secretive that
all but a handful of officials were kept
in the dark their assignment which has
not been previously reported was to meet
the Australian ambassador who had
evidence that one of Donald Trump's
advisers knew in advance about Russian
election meddling after tense
deliberations between Washington and
Canberra top Australian officials broke
with diplomatic protocol and allowed the
ambassador Alexander Downer to sit for
an FBI interview to describe his meeting
with the campaign adviser George
papadopolis the agent summarized their
highly unusual interview and sent word
to Washington on August 2nd 2016
two days after the investigation was
open the report helped provide the
foundation for a case that a year ago
Thursday became the special in Bell
County line' vestigation but at the time
a small group of FBI officials knew it
by its codename crossfire hurricane
that's in the name was a reference to
the the Rolling Stones lyric I was born
in it crossfire hurricane because
obviously now everybody was under
investigation so his crossfire hurricane
well days after they closed their
investigation into Hillary Clinton's use
of a private email server agents began
scrutinizing the campaign of her
Republican rival the two cases have
become inextricably linked in one the
most consequential periods in the
history of the FBI
this month the DOJ is expected to
release the findings of its lengthy the
review of the FBI's conduct in the
Clinton case and the results are sure to
renew debate over James Comey and the
FBI all of those questions I think are
perfectly legit but here's what people
are really worried about ok those
decision stands in contrast to the FBI's
handling of crossfire hurricane
only two agents in that case fall back
to their typical policy of silence but
interviews with a dozen current and
former government officials and a review
of documents show that the FBI was even
more circumspect in that case than has
been previously known many of the
officials spoke on condition of
anonymity because they were not
authorized to discuss the investigation
publicly agents considered then rejected
interviewing key Trump associates which
might have sped up the investigation but
risked revealing the existence of the
case top officials quickly became
convinced that they would not solve the
case before election day which made them
only more hesitant to act when agents
did take both of the investigative steps
like interviewing the Ambassador they
were shrouded in secrecy fearful of
leaks they kept details from political
appointees across the street at the GAO
Jason were telling the goj fearful that
all this stuff was going to leak the
facts had they leaked might have
devastated the Trump campaign Trumpton
future National Security Advisor Mike
Flynn was under investigation as was
Paul Manafort one adviser appeared to
have Russian intelligence contact that
would be Papadopoulos another was
suspected of being a Russian agent
himself that would be Carter Paige
the FBI faces a lot of criticism but
here is the actual story right buried in
the buried deep in this New York Times
piece crossfire hurricane spawned a case
that has brought charges against former
Trump officials and more than a dozen
Russians but in the final months of 2016
agents faced great uncertainty about
facts and how to respond so crossfire
hurricane began exactly 100 days before
the presidential election but if agents
were eager to investigate mr. Trump's
campaign as Trump has suggested the
messages do not reveal it I cannot
believe we are seriously looking at
these allegations in the pervasive
connection struck wrote as Peter struck
who is the one of the FBI agents whose
anti-trump soon after returning from
London the mood in early meetings was
anxious former officials were called
agents had just closed the Clinton
investigation they braced for months of
republican-led hearings over why she was
not charged crossfire a hurricane was
built around the same core of agents and
analysts who investigated mrs. Clinton
none was eager to re-enter presidential
politics former officials said
especially when the agents did not know
what would come of the Australian
information so the FBI investigated for
unidentified Trump campaign aides in the
early months they were Mike Flynn Paul
Manafort Carter Page George papadopolis
Flynn had been paid forty five thousand
bucks by the Russian opera by the
Russian government's media arm that brt
for 2015 speech and dined with Vladimir
Putin Manta Ford of course has deep and
abiding ties with the Russian government
via Ukraine Carter page was well known
to the FBI because he'd been preview
recruited by Russian spies and then
there was Papadopoulos the young
inexperienced campaign aide whose wine
fueled conversation with the Australian
ambassador set off the investigation
before hats democratic emails appeared
online he had seemed to know that Russia
had political dirt on mrs. Clinton so if
you recall Papadopoulos had apparently
died with a London professor who's an
agent of Moscow who said that he had
access to all these emails and then
Papadopoulos was talking to the
Australian ambassador and he said by the
way I know that the Russians have these
emails and so the Australian ambassador
called up the FBI and they said um guys
Russia's interfering in your election
and then the FBI went over and
interviewed this guy so does it sound
like the FBI has done anything wrong in
investigating these people looking at
all the information looking at what they
knew at the time let's say that it had
been Hillary Clinton and a top campaign
aide to Hillary Clinton let's say that
Hillary Clinton's future national
security advisors have been paid by
Russia today let's say that Hillary
Clinton's campaign chair had been deep
in bed with Vladimir Putin let's say
that a low-level
foreign policy staffer had been working
with the Russians to bring across
material about Donald Trump would you
have said the FBI ought to investigate
that of course would have said the FBI
ought to investigate that because the
FBI ought to investigate that right I
mean they didn't do anything wrong in
launching the investigation as far as I
can tell even if you believe that they
use shoddy information to go after
Carter page that is a slightly different
contention than saying the entire
investigation never should have been
launched that was a witch-hunt
from the very beginning okay now what
exactly did they do apparently
they said that they had embedded a an
informant deep in this piece it says the
FBI obtained phone records and other
documents using National Security
Letters a secret type of subpoena
officials said and at least one
government informant meant several times
with Carter page and George papadopolis
current and former officials said this
has become a politically contentious
point with mr. Trump's allies
questioning whether the FBI was spying
on the Trump campaign or trying to
entrap campaign officials but the real
question again is were they not
aggressive enough were they too
aggressive I understand the the sort of
right wing talking point that the FBI
was out to get Trump but it doesn't wash
for me you know Kimberly's frassle makes
the strongest case offered The Wall
Street Journal she says a few important
points on their new New York Times
hurricane crossfire piece a story that
by the way all of us following knew this
had to be coming this is the DOJ FBI
leakers attempt to get out in front of
the facts that Devon Nunez is forcing
out to make it not sound
don't buy it it's bad the biggest take
away government sources admit that
indeed the Obama DOJ and FBI spied on
the Trump campaign spied because she's
saying they had an informant NYT slips
in confirmation far down in its story
and makes it out like it isn't a big
deal it is a very big deal in
self-serving desire to get a sympathetic
story about its actions DOJ FBI leakers
are willing to provide you get more
details about that top-secret source
namely that the spine was aimed at page
and Papadopoulos making it all more
certain that they will be outed which is
on them DOJ and the FBI have shredded
what little credibility they have in
claiming they cannot comply with Devin
Nunes is subpoena so Devin Nunez the
chair of the House Intelligence
Committee he subpoenaed the DOJ and the
FBI for all the information about the
Trump campaign investigation basically
and they've not been turning any of this
over saying that it's dangerous for them
to turn it over they should turn it over
this is a congressional oversight
committee if it gets leaked that's on
the Congressional Oversight Committee
but the Oversight Committee exists for a
reason
Kimberly's rassul continues back in
December the New York Times assured us
it was Papadopoulos downer convo that
inspired FBI to launch
counterintelligence operation on July
31st 2016 that would be the conversation
between Papadopoulos the the low-level
foreign policy adviser and the
Australian ambassador this was
convenient since it diminished the role
of the dossier however now New York
Times tells us FBI did not debrief
downer until August 2nd and noonas said
no official intelligence from allies was
delivered to FBI about that conversation
prior to July 31st so how did the FBI
get those details and what really did
inspire the CI investigation okay so now
the implication that she is drawing is
that the real reason that the
investigation was launched was not this
meeting between the Australian
ambassador and George papadopolis it was
not Papadopoulos that launched the
Russia collusion investigation than what
originally launched it was the
politically motivated dossier that had
been paid for by fusion GPS at the
behest of the Hillary Clinton campaign
that still does not answer the question
as to whether everything in that Tasi a
is false okay that is still not been
confirmed for people who say the dossier
is all lies all untruths there is a
bunch of stuff in there that is probably
untrue
there is some stuff in there that is
probably not untrue and it's a mistake
to simply dismiss facts because it's
more convenient for the narrative to do
so
finally Kimberly's transyl says on that
if you're wondering who narrated this
story no paragraphs that assure
everybody that hardly anyone in the DOJ
knew about the probe Owen Comey was
given a few details nobody knew nothing
so he says that the basis she's
basically suggesting that they're a
bunch of
were involved in this nefarious plan to
take out Trump I am not seeing the
evidence that there are a lot of people
involved in nefarious plans take out
president from now I will tell you in
one second
what the nefarious plan actually was
like where it actually got in affairs I
don't think got nefarious during the
campaign I do think it got nefarious
after the campaign I'll explain in just
a second first you're gonna have to go
over to Daley wired.com and subscribe so
for $9.99 a month you can subscribe to
daily wire comm when you do I really
awesome giveaway right now so if you
described today like now as in right now
if you subscribe right now then you can
get one of those last VIP tickets for
Dallas or Phoenix because tonight it's
open to everybody and that means that
the chance of you getting those tickets
are a lot lower so if you subscribe
right now for $9.99 a month you have a
chance at the VIP tickets and and
getting your tickets early to the big
event that is coming up in August in in
Phoenix in Dallas so check that out
also you get the rest of the show live
tomorrow we have the mailbag you want to
ask me questions in the mailbag I'll
only answer the other if you pay me
that's the way it works so check it out
at daily wire.com when you subscribe for
$9.99 a month also the annual
subscription is $99 a year and you got
this the very greatest in beverage
vessels leftist here's hot or cold
tumblr look at its magnificence gaze
upon its beauty and mourn that you have
not one check it out
ninety-nine dollars a year and you can
have one and then you will be refreshed
both in body and in soul so check that
out right now also you just want to
listen later for free go over to iTunes
go over to YouTube please subscribe
please leave us a review it always helps
we are the largest fastest growing in
terms of podcast in the nation and also
please check out daily wire over at
Apple news because the Apple News does
indeed have all of our stories over
there as well
[Music]
all righty so as I say I am NOT fully
convinced that this New York Times story
about hurricane crossfire is this
damning indictment of the FBI or the CIA
and the FBI NCI launched this
investigation on zero grounds and it was
always a witch-hunt designed to take
down President Trump in the same way I
don't believe the Russian story I also
don't believe the FBI collusion story
that the FBI was colluding to take down
Trump I just don't buy it now the DOJ is
a different story right this is why I
think it's important to know who and the
DOJ knew what when because Loretta
Lynch's DOJ was corrupt through and
through just as Eric Holder's DOJ was
corrupt through and through the Obama
DOJ was just the most Eisley of law
enforcement it was it was a wretched
hive of scum and villainy the Obama DOJ
is just a garbage place but that's a
different story than the FB i-- and CI
should they have launched an
investigation again if Hillary Clinton
had been surrounded by a bunch of people
who appeared to be trying to do business
with the Russians and then Chelsea
Clinton had had a meeting with a Russian
lawyer promising dirt on Donald Trump
we'd all be like yeah I'm glad there's
an investigation going on so I don't buy
the the investigation was launched under
for prurient nonsensical reasons I don't
buy that now here's where it does get
dirty I think after the election
happened then a bunch of deep Staters
meaning Obama holdovers inside the FBI
and CIA decided you know it'd be awesome
it'd be great to undermine Trump's
presidency by leaking out all of this
information now this is the excuse that
they use for leaking is that Trump was
gonna come in who's gonna shut down the
investigation and destroy the
possibility of us uncovering all this
collusion yeah I think the reality is
more like there are a bunch of people
who are ticked that Hillary had lost
they did not expect Hillary to lose they
could not believe that this dunderheaded
Trump was president and they were going
to undermine him from day one by leaking
a bunch of information that really was
not criminal it was not criminal for
Michael Flynn to be talking to the
Russian ambassador Sergei Kesley act
that was not a criminal act when he lied
to the FBI that was criminal but it is
not criminal for him to be on the phone
with Sergei cos lyac about sanctions
against Israel for example that's silly
but that's all the stuff that was
leaking I do think there are Obama
holdovers who are leaking that sort of
stuff and I think that it is Obama
holdovers who are now leaking a lot of
the stuff with regard to Michael Cohen I
want to discuss in just a second
the situation with Michael Cohen because
they're a bunch of scurrilous leaks
about Cohen that are coming out that I
don't know why in the world they would
be breaking except for relatively
nefarious reasons so here's the story
today it turns out that there's a long
article by Ronan Farrow over at The New
Yorker about about the the Michael Kohn
financial file so there's a couple of
stories about Michael Cohen that have
come out in the last 24 hours
one is from The Washington Post as a
wonk a California man who says he served
as a translator last year for Michael
Cohen and a South Korean aerospace firm
that paid Cohen's company a hundred
fifty grand
said Tuesday that FBI agents recently
interviewed him Marco said in an email
to the Washington Post he spoke with the
FBI about the arrangement a few weeks
ago Co declined to provide details about
investigators enquiries said he was
unsure whether the agents were part of
the probe led by Special Counsel robert
muller so apparently cohen was trying to
go after south korean cash and now
there's a story from the intercept which
was very anti-trump outlet saying in the
blink of a michael a vanity tweet
alcaman all true Mikey has suddenly
found himself internet-famous
it began on Sunday evening when the
attorney for adult film star stormy
Daniels posted a screenshot of video
footage from Trump's tower lobby
recorded on December 12 2016 viral
speculation followed with online
detectives identifying all rumah he the
former head of a 100 billion dollar wing
of the Qatari sovereign wealth fund in
the image and linking him to a Qatar
Russia deal to sell a portion of the oil
company Rosneft which had been
referenced in the steel dossier from
their slate took over headlining a piece
Michael cones meeting with Michael Flynn
and a Qatari diplomat might be the key
to unlocking the steel dossier the
suggestion being that Qatar was trying
to bribe Michael Cohen to broker
basically a business deal for the sale
of Roth's of Rosneft apparently all room
I he said the Cohen asked him for an
upfront fee of 1 million dollars for his
services in the midst of their
conversation about a potential Qatari
investment in u.s. infrastructure the
question is how's Mike 1180 getting all
this stuff right how is it that all of
these news outlets are obtaining the
financial records of Michael Kohn and
according to Ronan Farrow the answer is
that did somehow people were afraid that
these documents were going to be
destroyed now this was the same excuse
that was being used with regard to the
leaks about the Muller investigation
before was the Muller investigation was
just the FBI investigation into Russian
collusion excuse for leaks was Trump's
gonna come in he's gonna destroy all the
documents Trump's gonna come in he's
gonna shut down James Comey and the FBI
Trump's gonna come in and all this is
gonna come to a screeching halt so we
got a leak this stuff we got a preserve
the information and distribute it well
now they're doing the same thing with
regard to Michael Collins financial
records there's only one problem
there's not really a threat and Mike
financial records are disappearing
Benjamin witness okay who's a senior
fellow at the Brookings Institute and
the editor of lawfare blog he is not a
Trump acolyte he says quote I've been
thinking about this New Yorker story on
financial records missing from a
government database I don't want to rain
on anybody's parade here but colored me
at least a little bit skeptical assume
for a moment that some records of Cohn's
transactions are in fact missing that
doesn't mean the transactions themselves
have disappeared only the Treasury
Department's record of the back reports
on the transactions are gone from the
database so when Bob Muller or the SD NY
the Southern District of New York
subpoenas the bank as they surely have
done already for the records of all
Cohn's transactions those transaction
records will still be there and they'll
be turned over
moreover the bank's sure the bank surely
still has records of the transactions
themselves so I doubt very much there's
a material loss to Mullah or the SD NY
in any pending investigation even if
there has been in fact some data loss
within the government nor ever was such
a data loss to be discovered and the
destruction were intentional malicious
that be traceable and that would be
prosecutable presumably so and then this
excuse that is being used to go after
Michael Cohen is obviously an excuse as
well so this is why I say it's not that
there's no corruption is that the
corruption is not where you are looking
for the corruption the corruption is in
the links the corruption is in
distributing information to the press
that should not be in the hands of the
press the the corruption is in the
post-election attempt to destroy Donald
Trump by leaking a bunch of information
that has not been confirmed that has not
been verified and then that has not been
traced to any sort of real collusion
that's the real problem here not the
investigation itself it's in the
investigation itself I think was
probably generated along correct lines
we'll see how it was how it was pursued
it is possible that prosecutors were
overzealous and how they pursued it with
regard to for example the Carter page
FISA warrant we'll find that out that's
what 7 News believes he believes that
the the going theory is that the FBI and
the CIA were basically working to go
after the Trump campaign and malicious
fashion by garnering warrants on
scoreless bases in order to discredit
well the Carter page FISA warrant came
about after the election so maybe that's
true maybe there's a possibility of that
that's not the same thing as saying the
investigation itself was launched in in
nasty fashion or for no reason at all
it's not the same thing as saying the
entire investigation is inherently
tainted that that's a different argument
and I think we ought to be very specific
about these arguments that we can be as
factual as possible none of this of
course means that actual collusion took
place there was intent to clue
the part of Donald Trump jr. pretty
clearly but that is not the same thing
as a crime because collusion itself has
a statutory definition that includes
conspiracy and the conspiracy just
doesn't exist here there's no
information changing hands there's no
impact on the election and therefore
there's not a lot to say about it other
than an attempt to discredit Trump and
his victory in the first place okay
meanwhile the Democrats continue to
struggle for air so their generic ballot
lead is now down to four point seven
percent in the latest Real Clear
Politics poll average this is because
the Democrats have staked everything on
the Russia investigation what's amazing
about the Democrats is how dumb they are
so after Trump was elected if the
Democrats had any brains at all what
they could have done is they could have
come around and said hey you know mr.
president you seem like a pretty swell
guy and you get a lot of money to us in
the past and we feel like we can work
with you you're a good guy and York guy
we can get some deals done sure here
look let's just do some nationalized
health care just a little bit let's see
some nationalized health care the chance
of the Trump sign that would have been
about 53% okay because Trump is not an
ideological conservative he's governed
as a conservative one of the reasons he
has governed as a conservative is
because the Democrats have decided that
he is Satan and he must be destroyed
from without well they have nothing else
to offer other than we hate Trump and
Russia and Michael a vanetti and stormy
Daniels stormy Daniels by the way who is
making a literal bare ass of herself I
mean she is she's literally gonna go to
a there's an apparently a statue of
President Trump naked in Seattle or
something and she's gonna go do a lap
dance with the naked statue up from I
can't imagine why people aren't taking
the stormy Daniel stuff seriously it
seems to me that she's a very serious
person deserving of nothing but
intellectual respect and also yeah she's
gonna go spank a naked statue with a
with the magazine but other than that I
think the totally yes Michael a vanetti
sure he's threatening journalists online
who are merely reporting on him but I
think that he's a real legit figure
these are all real legit people the
Democrats have staked their entire
fortune and and and their political fate
on Michael Evan Eddie and stormy Daniels
good luck with that well they don't
really have much choice because their
alternative is to say things like keith
Ellison so keith Ellison who is almost
the head of the DNC Democratic
Representative for Minnesota he actually
made the case yesterday we got to
regulate employer pay so you have a
booming economy incomes are rising like
in real terms they're rising the economy
is reaching historic heights and Keith
Ellison solution is
we should use the government to force
employers to pay particular wages on the
upper end and the lower end yeah I can't
imagine why people don't trust Democrats
around the government I mean this is not
a big secret to shareholders and not a
big secret to boards of directors
don't you need direct government
invention are you favoring the
government actually regulating the
relationship between CEO pays and the
average worker I think it's a very good
idea and I think we should start talking
about it okay so great I'm glad the
Democrats are coming out of the woodwork
well done guys just keep going keep
going it's amazing there's so far to the
left that they don't even understand
there they're blowing the greatest
opportunity for re-entry to power that
they've had in quite a while
okay time for some things I like and
then some things I hate and then a quick
Bible review so things I like so
yesterday or Sunday I believe Tom Wolfe
died the novelist Tom Wolfe there's
another really terrible death today
Richard Richard pipes who's a terrific
historian of Russia I'll recommend one
of his books tomorrow on the show
probably but Tom Wolfe was of course one
of the great nonfiction journalists of
the 20th century
he's also a very good novelist his first
huge book was bonfire - the vanities as
I said yesterday the first half of this
book is just tremendous the second half
of the book it kind of bogs down a
little bit but the first half you read
it as a conservative like wow this is
this is a gutsy book I mean the book
begins with a kind of yuppie leftist
liberal character driving into a heavily
black area and being and being so afraid
of crime that he promptly runs over a
black guy near his car and then he hit
and runs him and the and the book begins
with an attempted race riot by now
Sharpton character it's just it's an
intense book it's an intense book go
check out bonfire of the vanities Tom
Wolfe is always a great social satirist
and this obviously is evident in bonfire
of the vanities so check that out okay
other things that I like one of the
things that is obvious about the Trump
administration's decision to move the
embassy in Israel to Jerusalem is that
this should actually facilitate peace
because it may take off the table an
area of contention that should not be an
area of contention Israel is not going
to stop existing Israel is not going to
give up Jerusalem Bibi Netanyahu makes
that point yesterday on Vice vice of
course their coverage of Israel has been
absolutely egregiously awful but here's
Bibi Netanyahu making what is a very
fine point on Vice because a piece
that's based on lies will crash on the
rocks of millions reality
and it's time to to tell the
Palestinians abandon your fantasy of
destroying Israel that in the fantasy
that we will conquer Jerusalem abandon
the fantasy that says Israel disappears
it will not good
well they he's exactly right the left
would prefer a false peace based on
false promises then they would a real
piece based on realities on the ground
because then they don't get to paint
their false moral picture of what's
actually happening in the Middle East
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
so good news the Democrats can't call
Hamas terrorists they say that there was
some people shot on the border even
after Hamas suggested that it was not as
a bunch of Comus terrorists they won't
call ms-13 terrorists or or animals
they'll say that that that ms-13 they're
just a bunch of natural illegal
immigrants I guess I mean I I don't know
how else to take their interpretation of
President Trump's comments and now
debbie Wasserman Schultz has labeled the
real terrorists she did an interview
with The Huffington Post and she says
quote the NRA is kind of just shy of a
terrorist organization they've done
everything they can to perpetuate the
culture of violence that we have in our
country with the spread of assault
weapons across the nation
good job Democrats well done so just to
get this straight
Hamas not terrorists ms-13 not animals
NRA members terrorists no you're not
alienating the American public at all
you're not alienating the American
public at all when you say that
law-abiding gun owners are the real
terrorists but Hamas terrorists who use
babies as human shields are not
terrorists by the way there's that story
about an eight month old baby that died
in the in the crossfire in Gaza well or
what died after after being supposed to
tear gas and the question asked
yesterday is why that baby was anywhere
near the tear gas in the first place he
takes a baby to a protest where you know
that it that it's a riot essentially who
does that beyond that there's a doctor
who's now reporting today they actually
died of a pre-existing medical condition
so it had nothing to do with the tear
gas in the first place didn't stop the
media from reporting it they buried it
in paragraph 15 I believe of a New York
Times report yesterday so well done
media all the way through yes you want
to talk about political polarization it
started before Trump it will last after
Trump the left is pushing it in a really
heavy way it ain't just Trump who's is
the who's the creator of the sort of
political polarization we're seeing okay
so it's a Thursday which means that I'm
gonna do a little bit of Bible talk
normally
Wednesday but I'm a day late tough deal
with it so we're going through the Bible
yes last week we did the first chapter
of Joshua so I'm going through it
chapter by chapter because we've already
gone through the five books and Moses we
did that I think last year so now we're
going through the story of Joshua so
Joshua 2 is the story of raka raka was
the the that was in in Jericho and
Joshua and the Jews invade the land and
when they get to Jericho which is a
walled city Joshua and some of his other
spies they go into what some of the
spies of Joshua they go into rock hubs a
whorehouse essentially and the and
people are looking for them and they and
she advises them on how they can get
into the city and she says now that I've
advised you on how to get in the city
and how I'm going to hide you and she
hides them then I'm going to I'm going
to need your protection and here's what
it says this is Joshua 2:8 before the
spies lay down for the night she went up
on the roof and said to them I know that
the Lord has given you this land and
that a great fear of you has fallen on
us so that all who live in this country
are melting in fear because of you we
have heard how the Lord dried up the
water of the Red Sea for you when you
came out of Egypt and what you did to
see hone and oak the two kings of the
amorite Sea east of the Jordan whom you
completely destroyed when we heard of it
our hearts melted and fear and
everyone's courage failed because of you
for the Lord your God is God in heaven
above and on the earth below the reason
that I read this is because it's
actually a really bad description of why
you ought to believe in God there's this
you know the reason that she is saying
that people are believing in God is
because God is demonstrating his mastery
through human beings it is a bad reason
to believe in God however it is also a
very common reason to believe in God and
putting the fear of God in someone is
not just a phrase
putting the fear of God in someone
requires Western civilization to stand
up for itself it is not just enough for
you to say my principle to my principles
and I stand here on my principles when
you are fighting evil people you have to
protect yourself when you are fighting
evil people you have to demonstrate that
you are capable of winning that is why
what is real is doing why what America
does in the world it matters it matters
on a military level ok the truth
truthful propositions are not
self-evident and for the vast majority
of people over the vast majority of
history they've not been self-evident
that does not mean you should be an
aggressor it does mean that if you
strongly defend your own values either
rhetorically or if you're put under
threat physically people are more likely
to believe that what you're saying is
true ok we'll be back here tomorrow with
all the latest and with the mailbag i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah
of era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018